ok so I think you're gonna find this
interesting I was going to be on Fox
News over the weekend I was on Fox News
a few months ago and I was invited back
over the weekend I was going to be on
Saturday at 1:30 p.m. Eastern Time with
Leland Vitter's during their sort of
afternoon right wing news that they do
on every weekend I was going to be
debating the topic of the recent
Obamacare decision in Texas with a
conservative radio host named RJ
I believe it's RJ Harris RJ something
but RJ Harris I think is his name I was
booked on Fox News that morning they
sent me an email a little after 9:00
a.m. saying it the new ruling on
Obamacare is the topic for your panel
let me know if you have any questions
they had some source links everything
was good to go now I made a mistake I
didn't ask for a ride to the studio and
the reason I didn't is because when they
send you a ride they insist on bringing
you there so early that you just sit in
a chair with an earpiece for 45 minutes
literally with nothing to do so I prefer
to get there 10 minutes before the
appearance so I got got myself my own
ride I show up there it's a satellite
facility meaning it's not owned by Fox
it's a company that just does satellite
space they have a chair you can sit in
and you can join up with CNN or Fox News
or whoever and I ring the doorbell and
instead of ringing inside I can tell
that it goes to like a central number
for the company that runs these studios
and I say it's David Pakman I'm here for
my Fox News appearance and there's a
sort of confused
pregnant pause and then they say Fox
told us that was canceled I said how is
this possible it's just a couple hours
ago they confirmed the topic and and the
time they said we don't know it's just
but we don't work for Fox it's been
canceled so I ended up going back home
and ultimately getting a hold of the
producers and basically what they said
is oh it was canceled and what happened
is no one remembered to tell you like
yeah I know but I know that that's what
happened it was canceled and no one told
me that's the issue and there was no
further explanation given and
they offered to pay for my lift ride
down there it's not even worth the time
the time to submit for a reimbursement
for what the lift ride cost and people
started sending me every possible
explanation people saying David they
tricked you they wanted to waste your
time because you did so well on Fox News
last time and then not have you on they
don't have the time to do that as much
as you might attribute malice to this
it's just unprofessionalism that's all
it is it's not there's there's no one
there who says here's an idea in the
middle of booking an entire show
let's get David Pakman to just show up
at a studio and then there won't be any
segment like Pat this this is just
unprofessionalism and I'm proud to say
we've never done this to a guest ever if
we have to move something if something
gets postponed or has to be canceled we
are 100% communicating with them because
we value and respect the time of the
guests sometimes more than they respect
ours and our experience by the way but
we would never do something this
unprofessional absolutely true and I
remember when you went on Fox News back
in July we expected them to set you up
but to do so by the way that they frame
their questions and try to like get you
into traps and have this really weird
setup so you wouldn't sound all that
coherent and articulate this time they
set you up to fail in a totally
different way which is the no call no
show and I think this time they actually
succeeded in doing that they did and I
take these appearances seriously I spent
a couple hours in the morning
researching the topic making sure that I
was going to be ready because I know
that even though they say listen they
say I'm going to be debating a
right-wing radio host RJ Harris or
whatever but I know I'm really gonna be
debating the Fox News anchor and the
right-wing guy I know they're gonna
tag-team me I know I'm gonna show up and
the Lighting's gonna look ridiculous and
I'm gonna look like a vampire compared
to everybody else which is what happened
last time I was there I know that they
will lower my microphone when I start to
get argumentative and go back and forth
I'm okay with that because I still think
it's worth trying to break their echo
chamber and bust their safe space I'm
okay with that but just let me know if
you've cancelled it and definitely next
time if there is a next time although
there may not be the way things are
going I will just say listen based on
what happened
time you got to send me a ride I'm not
I'm not gonna get there on my own and
that way at least if the ride doesn't
show up it would be a hint that maybe
this segment has been canceled so I know
a lot of people were looking forward to
the appearance I had promoted it to some
degree and I think it would have been
absolutely great particularly because
right-wingers were making such a big
deal out of this Obamacare decision
which is immediately on hold like
literally a decision was made by a Texas
judge it's immediately on hold and you
can keep signing up for Obamacare and
nothing is changing and the immediate
and I was going to make that point and
tell them that they are fomenting a
false narrative and point out that the
article that they published about it
ignores the fact that nothing is
changing right now but it didn't happen
it didn't happen and that's that's a
shame would have been a great great
appearance